ich habe mich dazu entschlossen ein paar
von den verlorenen bzw retourierten DHL
Paketen zu den Empfängern
zurückzubringen und ihn zusätzlich noch
was zu schenken erstmal musste ich 300
Pakete durchwühlen und Leute aus meiner
Umgebung hier finden die erste Frau hat
auch gar nicht weit weg gewohnt sie hat
so ein fire TV Stick bestellt und das
war ihre Reaktion als ich dahin gefahren
bin und es war mir irgendwo auch sehr
unangenehm okay Leute wir sind jetzt bei
der ersten Adresse das ist so ich kann
sowas eigentlich gar nicht ne okay nicht
wundern ich habe hier ein Paket für sie
glaube ich ich habe vor einiger Zeit so
ganz viele Pakete aufgekauft von der
Deutschen Post und ich wohne halt hier
auch in der Nähe und ich habe mir jetzt
heute als Aufgabe ich mache mal so
Internet Videos weil ich habe gesagt
dass ich ein paar Leuten die Sachen
einfach wieder zurückbringen ich hoffe
wir sind jetzt erstmal nicht erschrocken
dass das bei mir überhaupt gelandet ist
weil das ist ja auch ein bisschen
komisch aber manchmal werden die Sachen
dann halt nicht zurückgegeben zum
Verkäufer und deswegen dachte ich
vielleicht können sie damit ja was
anfangen ich habe ihn auch noch ein
kleines Geschenk dazu gepackt können Sie
sich daran noch erinnern
dann schenke ich ihm das jetzt und da
ist noch Netflix Gutschein bei und dann
können Sie jetzt behalten